you can now access all of the sequence
read archive s vast public and
controlled access human data sets in the
cloud this transforms a laptop into a
high-performance computing device and
canoes struggles with speed and storage
issues you might encounter using FTP to
download large data sets from the NCBI
this short video demonstrates the steps
needed to access public SRA data on
Google cloud platform or GCP at the end
of the video you can link to a companion
video describing access through Amazon
Web Services I'll cover these three
activities setting up a new cloud
instance downloading and installing the
SRA toolkit within your instance and
configuring and testing the toolkit
installation to set up a new cloud
instance start at cloud.google.com and
if you are new to GCP first go to the
docs link in the upper right of the page
and if you just want to try out
accessing SRA data we suggest using the
GCP free tier you can read about how
that works here I've now signed into my
account and I've gone to the console to
start a new instance use the navigation
menu on the upper left of the page and
go to compute engine VM instances and
click create
I'll give my instance a name and for GCP
as long as the region and zone begin
with us you'll be fine and at the bottom
of the page click create I now have my
instance running you'll typically
interact with your instance via SSH
including for our next steps downloading
and installing the SRA toolkit the steps
for downloading the toolkit are nicely
laid out in our github wiki at NCBI /sr
a tools including installing and
configuration
I'm not going to show the download and
install but be sure to get the latest
version 2.10 point 3 or above I've
installed that version and I will show
configuring the toolkit because there
are a few critical steps required to
access these public data in the cloud
type VDB - config and - i to get an
interactive display for the
configuration the first requirement is
to enable remote access which should be
selected by default you can navigate
this config menu either by tab or
underlined letter type C and you can
decide whether you want data cached
locally or not and where you want it
cached if local cache is enabled be sure
that you specify a directory with
sufficient disk space the next two steps
are critical type G to set G CP as the
cloud provider then are to set report
cloud instance identity that's it for
configuring access I'll type s then o to
save and X to exit if you want to review
these steps in more detail see section
five toolkit configuration on the github
wiki page let's run a quick test of our
toolkit installation type faster queue -
dump and an S are our accession this
particular run takes several seconds to
retrieve and then there are the two fast
queue files that's all for this demo
we'd love to have your feedback in
questions so for help with SRA data and
the toolkit right to SRA
at NCBI NLM NIH gov and for feedback and
other questions please write to suggest
at NCBI NLM NIH gov